لكن ما هي شواهد الازمه ازمه الدولار في
العراق يكفي الانخفاض المشهود في قيمه
الدينار مقابل الدولار نتحدث هنا عن نحو
عشره بالمئه طبعا كل هذا
بمئه قواعد صارمه فرضتها واشنطن على
تعاملات البنك المركزي العراقي مع تجار
العمله
تقديمه تحويلات بالدولار على منصه جديده
على الانترنت مع المركزي العراقي لتتم
مراجعتها بعد ذلك من قبل بنك الاحتياطي
الفدرالي الامريكي
كما اعلنت واشنطن هو الحد من استخدام
النظام المصرفي العراقي لتهريب الدولارات
الى طهران ودمشق وملفات غسل الاموال في
انحاء الشرق الاوسط قد تكون الاجراءات
المطلوبه من واشنطن مفهومه لكن ما المشكله
في العراق بحسب البنك المركزي العراقي فان
المنصه المتعلقه بطلبات الحصول على
الدولار تطلب تفاصيل كامله عن العملاء
الذين يريدون تحويلات ماليه بما في ذلك
المستفيدون النهائيون هنا تظهر المشكله
حيث يرتكب العملاء العديد من الاخطاء عند
تقدمهم بطلبات للحصول على الدولار وحين
تتم مراجعه البيانات
واكتشاف الاخطاء يطلب من البنوك تصحيحها
وهذا الامر يستغرق الكثيره من الوقت
لن ننسى ان هناك محطتين لتنقيح البيانات
البنوك العراقيه ثم الجانب الامريكي
لانه منذ بدء التطبيق هذه الاليات تم حظر
80 بالمئه او اكثر من التحويلات اليوميه
بالدولار في العراق التي بلغ مجموعها في
السابق اكثر من 250 مليون دولار في بعض
الايام
الصحيفه فان العراق يعاني من صدمه لانه
سمح بتجاوز كثير من التعليمات المصرفيه
العالميه طوال عقدين من الزمن في كل الاح
القرار الامريكي قبل باعتراضات كثيره
اهمها من رئيس الوزراء محمد الشاعر
السوداني الذي قال ان القرار يضر بالفقراء
وكشف عن ارسال وفد الى واشنطن لمناقشه
تعليق الاليه لسته اشهر
الى العراق وندخل اكثر في تفاصيل الازمه
مع منتظر الرشيد من هنا
تشهدوا البورصه الماليه المحليه في بغداد
في جانبي الكرخي والرصافه وانخفاضا كبيرا
في عمليات بيعه وشراء الدولار على خلفيه
تذبذبي اسعاره سعر الصرفي مؤخرا
اقبال التجار لتمويل الشراء بضائعهم على
سحب كميات كبيره من الدولار عن طريق السوق
السوداء بعيدا عن البنك المركزي للتهربي
من المساءله القانونيه والضرائب ادى الى
ارتفاع سعر الصرفي في الاسواق المحليه
البنك المركزي ولي الحدي من ارتفاع سعر
صرف الدولار اكد انه زود المصارف الحكوميه
بكميات كبيره من الدولار وباسعار الرسميه
لكن ذلك الى الان لم يفلح في كبح جماح
الاسعار من بغداد منتظر الرشيد العربيه